hello everybody and welcome to let's
play Orcs Must Die - I'm here with Tom
say hi hello that's him that's him right
there that's my brother Tom owner and
the creator of two kinds if you know him
you're probably good so anyway we're
playing a little Orcs Must Die - on warm
age hopefully everything is set up a
story with an endless mode now I might
be fun later on alright let's go let's
do this don't fail even though you're
probably way better at this game than I
am haha hi somehow doubt it No
was this how it would end trapped
surrounded of my power lost
I deserved so much more they were coming
for me once I was their queen now they
would be my do know where you ripped it
was different
fragile it's a trickle of power
returning barely there not enough to
mind control even a single orc still the
rift offered an escape
as soon as I stepped through I saw him
standing right in front of me with that
ridiculous grin plastered across his
face I only had one thing to say run aah
I didn't know that the the female
character was the bought the bad guy
from the previous one yeah I heard about
that right
just as eloquent as ever anyway I got a
blunder boost now obviously we me and
Tom here at both played Orcs Must Die
one so we get the gist of the game
so obviously you trap Vice traps slow
down mix logo do you have different
traps than I do I think I do really cuz
that's like some ice thing that I see
going on there yeah I don't recognize
any of these traps holy crap
well uh don't fail yeah I got to get
used to this no time no time cuz here
they come
ah dammit I can't start it without you
well what the hell is that freezing
things I guess daling season
dudas what's your spell two main attack
uh staff that are one something a little
zabi thing well not bad oh I don't need
a head shot to kill
I got a new gun it's a blunderbuss it's
like a shotgun type thing well like a
musket yeah I like the precision of the
the other one a bit better
I could shoot more with it
and guys if there's problems with the
volume we're still trying to get it
figured out what the hell is that acid
what come on new stuff and you have my
Amana than I do so I guess you'll get
way more spells than I will and what's
this red thing help
I don't know it's like some something
for the minecarts alright so I can't
kill him with one shot I got it I think
got a head shot I thought they were just
calling back oh I could charge this
thing who aren't you
- yeah Jamin
I also know that there's new
but I think some of those armored guys
are Jewish or the lesser guys they look
different yeah definitely I bet this way
more customization yeah I haven't read
anything about this game so I don't know
either way what's go
I got something it was a skull not sure
what the deal was
wipe your feet well we don't have those
ladies yet
now damn oh well whatever in case you
guys didn't know enormous died one after
a while you got access to these ladies
give you special bonuses to your powers
I've just overall improved view
charmed yeah I guess I can the hell
that's my right-click ability right yeah
okay wait oh I have a right foot too
like a grenade
I'm bad okay this is much better i like
i like the blunderbuss better
because I always felt that the
right-click abilities in the first one
we're a little weak it depended on the
spell some of them were pretty good like
the electricity one that was my favorite
at least for the basic guns the basic
crossbow in you know yeah I know what
you mean a broad wimpy with it I'm
liking this sorceress yeah yeah may have
to switch off John there go more mark
mark one it's pretty easy so far oh
we're only on warm ages in the first
level I'm sure it'll get harder yeah
also I was only moderately good at this
but my brother Tom there he played the
crap out of nightmare
did you did you beat the game on
nightmare oh no I never got to it but uh
I got pretty far I think I got to the
second act oh it gets kind of stupid
hard after a while it's meant for
replayability with the world system
giant [ __ ] block yeah
and yes I know I'm very twitchy right
now this is how I play the first person
or third person married
me bro skills I got in my back pocket
Oh goodnight in space mana
if I'm in your way I don't really care
I wonder can I hit you what wait well
something I just saw something on the
mini-map goodbye I passed us why got
past us what how the hell
that's impossible what did you do I
didn't see anyone good obviously we
didn't get five skulls okay stats you
should have been paying attention
why weren't you paying attention I was
God why it ya see one got past us I
don't know how but one did so thank you
thank you for that
oh wait Spence kills my gear traps
vanity hell yeah no weapons oh there's
the crossbow
oh the crossbows much better because I I
need I can get headshots pretty good
with it I love the music I'm glad they
didn't change that yeah it's great
whenever you're ready I'm ready all
right I'm just gonna save them them yeah
because you don't know what to do with
the sorcerers yet
ah well let me leave waiting on you
there we go
grinders can kill a lot of kobolds
without jamming sounds good to me Hey
yeah here's that red thing again no I
fell down here why did you do that
there was an accident it was are you
[ __ ] around with me so they come out
where they come out of over there no way
to go in there Oh in here over here okay
I bet that other rifts gonna open up in
a soonish
Gobbo
yeah
now I wish I got a new spell I got it
wait how do we I thought it I thought I
had the crossbow where's where's Mike I
thought I oh why can't i activate my
crossbow did I screw something up
probably oh shut up okay
I don't worry about that yet that's not
even open let's go
Rajneesh so we must be in the human
world
trying to keep them from getting out
yeah I used to be that they were coming
Awards
it's weird I can hear that works just
fine but during the character dialogue
it's actually
yeah I noticed that maybe someday I just
country okay hold them off
right boss yes are you okay yeah yeah
boys volume is like maxed out what's it
Dale I don't know the nega yeah yeah
yeah whatever
sir subtitles that Ivan subtitles
whatever okay go
new rift is opening ah now we worry
about this one voila we come out of both
no just this one okay whatever you say
hey you got it my way I don't care oh
one fell down there oh oh that bad
uh-huh I think activated the minecart
did that help no kill you
no damn
now you keep knocking them down there
sorry actually not even a little bit
sorry that's how they got past us last
time
yeah actually every time they fell over
the side before I go sworn that I got
points because I thought they'd I'd set
it and forget it
I have no money I got this side I got
this side
except there's nothing coming out of it
shut up stay over there
I do not like this shot not accurate
enough
oh there they are
yeah I got that okay
I guess for a non coop match you might
shut that off I live from that door
got that oh yeah okay over there easy
peasy yeah whatever you die without me
oh I thought down here again why do you
keep going down there it's not my fault
wrong with you unleash hope there we are
on you I do not remember
down there a lot yeah we're gonna get
away now my fault through good guy I got
a big gun
put them on our side oh crap Oh always
flips I'm out of mana I'm looking in
trouble falling back
don't fail not good not good not good
it's fine don't fail
put some traps I don't have any more you
don't have any more traps I don't have
any dollar any more money money yeah
yeah we are we going to fail here
because of you because of you because of
me what did I do you left through Oh big
guy mommy a Charmin jet I shot him good
now keep it up
hey got it my way again not my fault
almost there we got this I'll had it in
the bag Oh in the bag that was easy
I was no trouble at all nope not even a
little bit Hey look
really which has a crossbow
I'm surprised that this guy and that
lady is working together
your care treatment evil
Finch well I guess beggars can't be
choosers what's she gonna do when she
gets all the power back she can go right
back to controlling the work probably
seems to be much more under control
unless you're failing over there uh
prevailing over there no oh boy so
everything's fine what have you done
nothing I'm unleashing the minecart for
something
I got him I'm here to save the day there
we go
oh that's five skills all thanks to me
yes shut up endless levels unlock a
screw that all right actually that's
gonna do it for this episode thank you
all so much watching and if you notice
obviously the webcam is not in this one
just because with two people talking and
with this type of game I didn't think it
was necessary thank you all so much for
dodge for watching if you liked the
video if you like this game please write
to in the comments and show your support
and say thank you with a Tom here Virgil
a me yeah that's him
shut up I'm talking alright okay anyway
me and him we're gonna be playing
through this game to the finish and
maybe some maybe he'll join me for a
livestream if I ever do nightmare mode
so thank you everyone for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye hi